[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france a 24 y ya está conmigo en el
estudio rosa pérez más de euros a
bienvenida feliz martes ya bueno
comenzamos nuestra sección y empezamos
por una de estas imágenes capturan
perfectamente la historia del encuentro
entre vladimir putin macrón que hoy abre
las portadas de los medios alrededor del
mundo y como también lo comentamos rosa
una reunión que estamos también a la
espera lo que va a pasar en esta rueda
de prensa con polo mini selenski porque
recordemos que macrón ahora se encuentra
y quiere reunió con el presidente
ucraniano
buenos días exactamente raúl aunque
difícilmente la imagen que puedan dejar
macro ni selenski va a superar la que
ayer dejaron a putin y el presidente
francés también que hoy está en las
portadas de muchísimos medios
internacionales y hemos querido
seleccionar pues por un lado el moscú
time por otro lado liberación que
respectivamente titulan putin dice que
está dispuesto a alcanzar un compromiso
sobre ucrania después de la conversación
con macrón o liberación que dice macrón
putin y diálogo a la rusa y bueno
destacan los textos respectivos
y aseguró que estudiará las propuestas
de macrón entre las cuales destacan que
ninguno de los bandos pues emprendan
nuevas acciones militares y por otro
lado pues en contrapartida hemos querido
destacar esta imagen de the hill un
medio especializado pues en la política
de washington en la que vemos al
canciller alemán olaf scholz y a la
presidenta de eeuu joe biden no porque
pues en oposición a esta frialdad que
separaba pues el escenario en el que se
encontraban macro ni putin pues vemos
aquí ambos dirigentes que se pues se
describieron como grandes aliados como
no podía ser de otra forma al lado de
esta chimenea de este calor y bien es a
destacar de esta reunión que tuvo lugar
en washington al que yo wyden no perdió
la oportunidad de pues dirigir un
mensaje al presidente ruso y asegurar
que si finalmente moscú invadía ucrania
pues que eeuu y de seguro que detendría
el proyecto del gasoducto nord stream 2
algo que no sabemos como sucedería dado
este proyecto pues no atraviesa tampoco
territorio estadounidense rosell es que
precisamente ese protagonismo asumido
entonces por el presidente francés
emmanuel macro es lo que critica el
diario le monde con su titular que dice
marco non quiere aprovecharse de la
crisis ucraniana a dos meses de las
presidenciales
efectivamente dice si viene una crisis
internacional nunca nunca ha sido
decisiva en una elección el jefe del
estado quiere hacer de su activismo
diplomático un arma de política interior
mostrar este peso internacional de cara
esta campaña presidencial pues que ya
está teniendo lugar a pesar de que
recordemos emanuel macro todavía no ha
oficializado su candidatura a lo que
sería la reelección cambiamos ahora del
tema pero vamos con el país que también
carga contra el presidente en este caso
contra pedro castillo adoramos el
presidente peruano dice perú
desgobernado exactamente y aquí en la
imagen que hemos seleccionado del país
pues solamente para pues insistir en
este tema pues vemos que en la portada
también lleva esta misma imagen a la que
decíamos referencia al inicio de la
sección sin embargo vamos
que básicamente señala que pedro
castillo ya ostenta el récord de
remodelación de un gobierno en los
últimos 40 años que concretamente en los
7 meses hay que llevar al frente del
gobierno de perú ha cambiado ya 21
ministros esto puedes hacer referencia
un poco también a lo que ha ido
sucediendo a lo largo de la semana
pasada cuando dimitió mirtha vásquez y
que pues pedro castillo para sustituirla
pues eligió a héctor valer quien hasta
pues enfrenta acusaciones de maltrato a
su mujer ya su hija así como otros
procesos judiciales y que finalmente
tres días después de su denominación
pues ha sido cesado y señala el
editorial del país que pues todos estos
problemas internos y externos pues
impiden pues sacar adelante la crisis en
las que está sumida pero rosa seguimos
en américa latina con el siguiente
informe que dice ellas alimentan el
mundo esto está explicado por maría
fernández camacho en el salto rosa
exacto esta periodista desde buenos
aires detallado un informe realizado por
la fm we effect que señala entre otras
conclusiones que 7 de cada 10 mujeres
campesinas indígenas y afrodescendientes
en colombia bolivia guatemala el
salvador y honduras que trabajan en la
tierra pero que sólo tres de ellas la
poseen y que en la mayoría de los casos
es por ser viudas o huérfanas muy
rápidamente rosa la imagen que
prometimos hallar
efectivamente y es que pues esta imagen
que dio la vuelta al mundo el año pasado
y que llegó a ganar el premio de
fotografía de siena en italia pues ha
sido reproducida por el medio the
gardian que ha ido al encuentro de este
padre y este hijo que protagonizaron
esta instantánea en la frontera de
turquía con siria pero que se encuentran
ya en italia después de que el jurado de
este premio de fotografía pues en
colaboración con instituciones
religiosas y con las autoridades
italianas y de turquía lograron
establecer un corredor humanitario para
atraer a la familia como a italia donde
ya ostentan el estatuto de refugiado y
lamentan pues que la mayoría de personas
que sufren a la guerra en concreto de la
guerra de siria no logren obtener este
estado ni tampoco poder atravesar estos
corredores humanitarios una figura que
está muy en desuso y pues aprovecha este
este artículo para señalar ahora que
hablamos tanto de la posibilidad de una
nueva guerra en europa para indicar
recordar que la guerra es la destrucción
total del área rosa usted se haría una
cirugía de estética pues de momento no
me lo planteado no sé todo puede ser hay
que saber hay que saber muy bien con
quién y eso se lo explico en nuestra
segura en nuestra primera invitada al
día rosa gracias